Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Yeah.
Ah,
the chicken in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
So you know your week's going.
How are you holding up,
how you're handling today's
top stories in the news? Um,
I haven't seen much about
it, but I guess Nike, uh,
got on board with the colon.
[inaudible] Colin Kaepernick, right?
Say, hey, sometimes you gotta do this
to get debt, right? And then everybody,
you know, you know the deal, you
know, people are, it's like, Hey,
my point is about police brutality
and ever since nine 11 a bit.
Yes sir. Sir. We're
not talking about that.
No one is saying that your
brother is not over in Iraq.
He's talking about police brutality.
What,
where the fuck out of the country.
And that right there
is political discourse
in 2018,
you know,
not saying people listen back in
the day, but at least they, they,
they did a better job pretending.
You know what?
Where does Nike get off acting like
they give a fuck about people. You know,
if they really, you gave a shit
about people when they, uh,
have allowed that documentary exposing
their fucking sweatshops to air at some
point. Oh, shots fired and bill, if, uh,
if you gave a shit, wouldn't you not
be wearing a Nike shirt right now? Hey,
fair enough. We're all full of shit. Um,
Jesus Christ.
If I see one more fucking moron.
Yeah,
yeah.
No screaming about troops or nine 11 on
a subject that has nothing to do with
it.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's a protest about police brutality.
He is allowed to do this.
The long allowed to misconstrue.
It's construe what he's saying, Dan.
You know,
but that's what it is.
I think that's what happened with
the Internet is now everything.
Even when it isn't about you,
it has to be about you.
Yeah.
You know, all of these fucking people,
you know what I mean? It's, it's, it just,
it just be all of this shit,
this fucking shit you see on Instagram
with a person's acting like they're
trying to inspire you.
When they're really just trying to show
you all the cars they have outside of
their fucking a giant
house with their abs.
You know the fuck was I
joking about that with,
I did the Bill Simmons podcast that
was joking about that. You know,
all these fucking celebrities always
telling you how hard they're working.
Yo, we out here grinding. It's
like everybody. Everybody is.
A lot of people weren't blessed. Most
people were not blessed with your gifts.
They're grinding does not fill an arena,
you know,
but there are really
good fucking carpenter,
but no one's going to sit there
and watch him frame of fuck.
While I guess you wouldn't
frame a house as a carpenter.
I finished copper numbers. I'm
thinking, what are you saying, bill?
That regular carpenters aren't as good as
finished carpenters? Well, I mean, yeah,
you can hide a lot of your
mistakes in the walls.
Hey,
my brother was a carpenter.
Um, he built a shack and I wreck,
that's not what I was talking about.
Ah,
I felt like yelling.
MMM.
Anyways,
I saw a little bit of it.
I saw somebody retweets something
and it was something about Fox News,
of course, trash and Kaepernick of
course saying he's not American. Uh,
and of course saying probably that,
you know,
he doesn't support the troops because
he's talking about police brutality.
Yeah.
Oh, the weather outside is frightful.
Um, so there you go. But um,
by all means, you know,
people, uh, you know,
don't burn your own property.
You know,
even if you don't like Nike's,
you could give it to a homeless guy.
And also when you burn that stuff,
you're just really polluting
your own environment. Yeah.
With all that rubber and God knows
what else is on the fucking sneaker,
what do you have to burn it? Why can't
you just throw them out or set them aside?
They always got to burn it.
I remember when Lane Kiffin lift
left fucking Tennessee in this guy.
Somehow it's some lane Kiffin
Jersey and he like lit it on fire,
filmed it,
and then pissed on it.
Okay.
You run
up and leave and Tanner
steep or book in USC.
Uh, what do you think about
an American Corporation?
Poisoning our own food supply.
What
are you going to let you cornflakes
on fire and then pee on him?
What are you and asked us,
what the fuck you talking about?
You Bald headed freckled
mother fucking Yankee cut.
Would the fuck you do now on here?
No southern guy ever said can't do.
They can if current and that's
how they'd say it. Good.
Um,
[inaudible]
why am I acting like it's everybody
down the south burning their Nike's?
I Dunno.
I don't know why.
There's not more people saying like
this was about police brutality.
You may or may not agree with it,
but to then try to make
it about something else,
which then leads you to burn your own
sneakers is probably not the direction you
want to go in. However,
that's not what you know.
But the thing is is if somebody is burning
their own sneakers and then you show
it on TV, like all of those channels
you have flipping through, right?
There's, there's the fucking the lawyer
chick, right? You flip the channel.
There's the, there's the Jack Ryan Guy.
You flip the channel is to Psi Phi.
You flip the channel.
There's a commercial you flip the channel
is a saga gave you flip the channel.
Somebody sneakers are on fire,
you're going, what the fuck is that
with somebody in those, when
those caught on fire, my God,
what? What? How do those sneakers catch
on fight fire and, but yet, you know what?
I think we cracked the code here.
People for anyone in Hollywood listening
to this, if you want to hit series,
you need fire. That'll make people
stop. But it's got to look real.
So in other words, you know, like
when you shoot without a permit,
you got to like light something on fire
without permission and then it'll look
real because it is real.
And if you can somehow capture the people
running out of whatever the fuck you
lit on fire,
then I think you could actually get people
to stop long enough and possibly sit
through some commercials that they
would allow your show to air for the
following week. So see, I
guess there is a silver lining
for the life of me.
I will never fucking understand people
that take it to that fucking level.
I get the UK, you're not agreeing. Well,
let's say you know it's about
police brutality, but you're like,
that's not the way to go about
protesting. Fine. I get that. Fair enough.
Good point to you sir or Madam. But when
like you take it to the point that like,
you know,
you're going to burn your shit
and then film it and then uploaded onto
the internet and no point during any of
that fucking process.
You like those sneakers when it was just
crying, children's sewing them together,
didn't you? You don't like
how fucked up. I mean, I mean,
how far back are we going to take
this? You know, if you really care.
All right,
Dan, you wouldn't buy those
things in the first place.
You'd be going down to the
fucking a sneaker factory
and given that little kid a
break and you'd sit down on the stool
and you'd fucking glue your shit together
yourself, wouldn't you, wouldn't you? Um,
I dunno. All I know is I'm sitting here
right now and I don't have the Internet.
I'm a 50 year old man. I don't have
the Internet. I don't know when.
I'm going to be able to upload this. Uh,
I once again upgraded my sister, you know,
my uh, buddy of mine was just telling
me, Greg Fitzsimmons just at his podcast.
I don't know when that's going to air.
Gee Cibele why are you doing
all these podcasts? Well,
cause I got some big tour dates coming
up in f is for family season three is
right around the corner.
The the fuckers done, man.
We're getting ready to start promoting.
MMM.
Well you bet. Promote [inaudible]
brought her over now ran.
Don't burn my sneakers.
I will burn my fucking sneakers.
Hey Nike,
I'll be watching.
Oh,
burning my fucking sneakers.
Don't make me burn my pole
over cause I'll fucking do it.
Yeah,
just do it. Yeah, I'll fucking do it.
I'll come over there like your
whole fucking factory on fire.
How dare you kneel during
the national anthem.
Yeah.
Do you have any idea how
disrespectful kneeling is?
Okay.
Whenever I go to church and pat,
she says everybody take their knees.
It's like, I will not disrespect God,
but getting on my fucking knees.
Everybody knows. If you
believe in Jesus, you stand up,
you go eyeball to eyeball with that
hip is some bitch and you see how you
measure up.
You look at him in the eye.
Yeah,
maybe you're a little taller looking
down on them being like, Hey Jay,
okay,
fuck was up with that hooker man.
Or maybe you you,
you want them a little fellows but
with a big heart. Just keep coming,
knock them down.
Keep coming like a fucking wolverine.
Fucking Michigan Wolverines
is sponsored by Nike.
I'm going to go in there and
I'm going to burn all of them.
Tight little yellow pants.
They run around it.
Ones that hug their
buttocks is in such a way,
I'm sorry people,
I don't have the Internet right now so I,
I can't look up anything about sports,
so you're just going to have to suffer
through another fucking 20 minutes of
this.
Yeah.
I'm contractually obligated to continue
running my fucking mouth for another 19
minutes.
The contract.
I signed with myself kind of like with
Motley Crue signed that contract that
they were never going to tour again
because if they did then I guess they're
going to sue themselves.
That's how that works.
Okay.
I'm sitting here right now.
I am staring at a VCR DVD player
and uh,
I'm trying to find, you know,
I don't have the Internet.
I'm trying to find a fucking
radio shack or something.
Oh Jesus. What did I just
do? I can't hear myself.
I can't hear myself. There we go.
Now I can hear myself. You know,
I just literally just fucking bought
this shit and now it doesn't work. I,
you know what, I'm going to bomb
in a blame Colin Kaepernick.
Uh, anyways, the fuck if
somebody texted me here,
allow me Andrew through
this Goddamn podcast. Um,
yeah,
there's best buy. Still sell the shit
you need for that. Does anybody know
that's one of those things, man, when
you hang onto the old technology,
cause I got all my old standup tapes over
here on VHS. I converted most of them.
And then there's other
ones and it's just like,
I don't know what the fuck's only
shit before I go send it over there.
Well,
trying to think,
did I ever make a porno?
You gotta ask yourself before
you send your VHS tick,
you ever hear VCR man,
it's this new fangled fucking machine.
Yeah.
Is it put out by Nacky
cause I light it on fire.
MMM.
Some redneck is going to go
to a Chinese restaurant and,
and accidentally light one of
the people that are on fire,
you know,
because he's going to give him a tip
and he's going to be like, do you like,
you know,
you like,
and she's going to be I likey and then
he's going to think she said Nike and
then let's see that. See how that happens.
It's a slippery slope. Once you start,
did you start lighting shit on fire man?
Like you don't know where,
where's it going to stop?
I mean, maybe if you do it,
you start to like it, right? And
then the next time you wife's like,
could you take the trash out
and you're walking over their shoulders
slump looking down at the linoleum
defeated man.
You get like a foot away from the
trash and suddenly just remember
how good it felt.
Like your own sneakers on fire.
All of a sudden you lift at fucking
hit up proud first time in years
and you knew like,
you know what?
Yeah,
you want me to take this trash out?
You fucking bitch.
I'll take it out.
I'm allotted on fire and I'm a film it
and I'm going to put it on the Internet.
Yeah.
And then we'll see what damn sneakers
sale and motherfuckers say ban.
MMM.
16 minutes to go.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
the red sox are playing 500 ball.
When is Chris sale coming back?
I have no, he's the guy. He
is the guy that prevents us
from slice of fucking funny.
Everybody I told,
you know I told those fuckers at ESPN,
they wouldn't listen to me. They don't,
they,
they are afraid to listen to this podcast
when they said the fucking Yankees got
swept. This fucking division
series is ober. Yeah,
he said that the first week of
fucking August. And what did bill say?
What did the balding freckled con to
never played baseball belong beyond the,
the minor or major leagues.
Okay.
Got kicked out of baseball because he
got a d in math in 19 fucking 79 was the
last time I played in an organized
league and even I could see it even I was
going, hey, wait a minute. ESPN.
Yeah,
there's like 60 fucking games left
and were up by nine and a half games.
I don't know what kind of fucking uh,
Muslim assets textbook you're looking at.
The numbers don't add up.
Um,
yeah,
we'll probably going
to win like 105 games.
I even know where the
fuck around right now.
Last I saw he's like 91 or 92 probably
go 500 for the rest of the fucking year.
You know, it's, it's never fucking Yogi
Berra said it's not over till it's over.
And he said that before there was
a wild card, a one game playoff,
19 fucking rounds of baseball.
He said that back when all you had to
do was win the fucking division and you
won the pennant and then you
had to win four more games.
You won the world series.
Even that fucking guy
who essentially mocked mentally
challenged people his entire life with is
planned out.
Goofy segs,
right?
Playing Glib the whole time, like a hot
chick trying to get some free drinks.
Never figured out what that
guy's angle was. Even he said,
it ain't over until it's over.
Who said what first
fine
sounded like Abbott and Costello who said
it ain't over till it's over first or
like what came first that or it
ain't over until the fat lady sings,
right.
Everybody knows if you want
to hear somebody could sing,
you got to get a fat
woman, right? Fat Woman,
fat woman listen to, we're saying, right.
Isn't that that theme song?
And they come walking out,
they always had some sort of flair
on for a code or some sort of, uh,
some sort of,
I dunno what something but
dazzle coming out day with,
they have fat feet fucking
just all squeezed into those little pumps.
Hello. Shayle Kann. Who? E. Right? Singing
the shit out of the national anthem.
Why would they sing at the end
of the game? You know why? I bet.
Because they didn't have fucking jumbo
trons back in the day. You don't see,
everybody's just walking out and all
you could hear was the sound of fucking
people stepping on empty peanut shells.
Just Racist Shit right there to stop
people from being racist to each other to
get them out of it.
And that's just the white people
you fucking day best. I mean,
you a fucking Irish bastard.
Fuck you're,
you're fucking Daigo right back there.
When like the Irish and the Italians,
like white people were like
racist against each other,
Polish people,
all of that shit.
They needed to keep them calm when
they walked out of the ballpark.
So then they just had some fat
lady come waddling out there.
Everybody could laugh at her
going, well, you know what?
I might have fucking tuberculosis release.
My feet aren't oozing out of my shoes.
Then she'd get out there singing
and our man, hey, how I lobby our,
I'm five foot two are
[inaudible] girl.
Okay.
Everybody just put on their
fucking derbies and they walked up.
Yeah,
take me out to the ball game.
Take me back to my neighborhood where
everybody looks like me and we fucking
cabbage for three cars where I rich
people in the Irish section of they'll
fucking town.
Keep your pasty freckled fucking
ass in your own neighborhood. Right.
So weird how they glorify that, that
error in sports. A simpler time.
The good old days or baseball.
They tell it two different ways.
They're either,
you have like that,
that version we're Billy crystal talks
about going to the Yankees game and
seeing Mickey Mantle or
they do the real shit,
the Jackie Robinson story
that it's just like, oh, okay.
And all in that see exact
same fucking footage.
Other than that black cat being
thrown on the field. Other than that,
it's all the exact same footage and how
you're viewing it has less to do with
what they're saying and more to do with
the music that they play underneath it.
11 minutes to go.
I don't have my rewrite now.
I'd be reading my fucking advertising
and I could get through this part,
but I don't fucking have it.
By the way. Butcher box. You're welcome.
I have blown up heritage bread.
Pork.
Okay.
I blown it up. I brought,
I brought it back.
It was so fucking far gone.
People didn't even know it was missing.
I had never heard, I been eating
pork chops my entire fucking life.
Bacon,
Ham and cheese sandwiches got older.
I moved to New York. I was introduced
to a Cuban sandwich. Right.
All of that fucking
what do they got their welcome
whenever I think I got to go fucking
cause you're dumb bill.
Oh that's probably it.
Pork Butt, right? Pork shoulder.
Is it really the acid of the pig and
they just say pork shoulder cause they
don't want you to be reminded, you
know they do say rump roast, right?
Hey all you guys out there burning
your sneakers. You know, you know,
you know you also have like
an apocalypse like game plan.
You know what I mean?
You like Bill Walsh,
she calling all the plays in the first
half and I'm just fucking showing up and
I'm not even gonna know what
the fuck's gonna hit me. Right.
I am an apocalypse plant to
die within the first hour.
Ah, Shit. That's that. I mean,
that is the ultimate plan,
you know, cause then I, then
I get to be a ghost. Right.
And I'm already as white as one.
Right. That might be my, my disguise.
The freckles would give me away.
MMM.
No, you die within the first hour and
then you just hang around. You want,
you know, like, remember Patrick
Swayze and uh, Moondance,
whatever that fucking movie was called,
our hair to Tam or
a dad or not judged with this chick
and her knows that she chose to change.
You knew way. That was weird. Um,
ghost Jesus Christ.
I said I wanted to be a fucking ghost.
Yeah, I remember that. When
he would look up at the light.
Evidently you have an option when you
die. All right? If you go into hell,
you don't have an option.
You just get manhandled.
Look like you grabbed some
chicks ass at the club.
These fucking Damon's just come up
and they just grab you and then that's it.
But if you lived a good life,
if you took out their trash,
I guess you could look up at the light
and God gives you the option and be like,
hey man, you want to come
behind the velvet rope? Or like,
do you just want to fucking, you want to
be a voyeur for awhile? I'm not judging,
dude. This isn't going to go against
your record. Okay, you done good.
You did good enough to get up here.
You know there's another train
coming in in a couple of weeks.
If you want to just fucking hang around,
you mean you got to hang around, right?
You've got to go Tom Sawyer and hang
out at your own funeral. That'd be,
that'd been no funerals
at the fucking apocalypse.
There'll be the old school once
they fucking dig up
fucking foot and a half
foot and a half trench deep trench.
You just hope they don't see anything
sparkling in the dirt or they're just
going to leave you out in the open
and keep digging. Is that uranium,
you know it's going to have an easy time
during the apocalypse is going to be
the hipsters cause they're already like,
they already have the
fucking grizzly Adams beard,
so let's stay warm in the winter.
They're already, you know,
they know how to make like their own
jam and fucking bear in the bathtub like
all this old school stuff. Some of them
know how to make their own clothes.
Like I think hipsters are going to be,
I think they're going to be all right
and we're all going to be like, wow.
You know what?
I remember I wanted to fight that kid
cause he told me that he's learning how to
be a blacksmith,
you know,
and the other kid was building a steam
ship and then all of a sudden the
apocalypse is going to happen.
You'd be like, you know something.
Those are some skills
I wish I had right now.
Oh Jesus Christ. This is like
the longest fucking podcast ever.
Okay, five minutes to go. Jesus
Christ, five minutes left.
Um, I'm going to be in
Sacramento this weekend.
Everybody know north of Sacramento.
I'm doing a casino up there
with a rose bowl tailgate.
Less legend.
Jason Lawhead,
master flat top grill,
Shep master smoker
math.
You put them on a green egg.
A fucking a standard fucking grill
demand is going to [inaudible] going
to make something. He just makes,
he makes everyone around him
better with like, you know,
it'd be like if you just add that player
that causes everybody to elevate their
game. The second we added Jason
Law, head to the fucking tailgate,
everybody had a few more
beers, right? Everybody?
Uh, I dunno. Eight a
little bit more everybody.
Everybody just took it a little bit more
and we got an extra room for the first
time ever.
We made it to the playoffs
of arguably the top whatever,
400 tailgates and our section though,
there's some people that throw down, man,
they bring like satellite dishes
and shit and like TVs, you know.
But I'm telling you,
you want to,
you want to bring the fucking
flat top fucking grill.
All right?
But the Goddamn propane tank,
none of that shit squat and around with
your little firebox trying to get the
coals burning and all of that shit.
Fuck that.
You just turn on the
gas week weekly Click,
let that fucking thing heat up.
Drink a bloody Mary.
And next thing you know fucking you making
yourself an egg sandwich with bacon.
Oh, delicious. Toasting up your egg mic.
Yeah, you're fucking Yah, Yah. English
muffins. That's just breakfast.
Now you've moved onto whiskey,
right?
It's fucking per,
I got the flat top going over a
over Labor Day. And by the way,
I'm telling you, I made the,
I made the practice burger. I took it
right out of the fridge and I was like,
you know, I should have fucking
had this been room temperature,
but I don't have the time. And I
threw it on. I did five minutes,
both sides. I made sure it was nice
and thin or whatever. Um, it was,
I guess a little too
thick and I took it off.
Had a nice crunch to it and everything,
but when I got to the middle,
it was like rare.
So I was like,
well thank fucking God. I didn't,
by the way, I ate it still.
I still ate it.
Fucking hamburger in the middle.
It was like the consistency of
bubblegum and a very dangerous,
very dangerous thing to do.
You can,
you can get away with that with steak
because you just fucking with one steer at
that point. But hamburger is just like
a million stairs, you know what I mean?
That's like, you know, eat that raw.
That's like going rob with a porn star.
You have no idea how many
people you just fucked.
So I took the meat out of the fridge,
got it at room temperature,
and then I did six minutes
on both sides and uh,
got nothing but compliments. So
there, there's a little tip for you.
This little tip that I learned from
a pro chef is you got to get up the,
you've got, you've got to hit a
fucking breakfast ball. All right?
You got to make one for yourself.
You make the mistake on your own.
All right. If I just took all that
meat out and just throw it on there,
everybody would have had bubble gum in
the middle of fucking raw meat in the
middle of their burgers.
They'd have to take the fucking buns off
and all of that messy shit and I'd have
to put it back on and everybody would be
looking at me like my balls just rolled
off the fucking porch.
What kind of a man doesn't know
how to cook over and open flame?
Huh?
That's what they would be saying.
Nope. Didn't say that about me
because in private when no one was around,
I failed miserably.
Okay,
well that's one to grow on for the
love of God. Is that 30 minutes.
Ah, 29 minutes. One minute to go.
People. What have we learned here?
We've learned that bill
can do a southern accent.
We've learned that anytime anybody's
dumb built as a southern accent,
we've learned that bill has
watched dirty dancing and ghost.
And, uh, I think I did an
advertisement for eating pigs and,
uh,
putting them on a flat top grill.
I don't know what else she
fucking need out of this. Um,
at some point this will be uploaded.
And the next thing you're
going to listen to his, uh,
audio of me on my cell phone,
probably reading
that should have already been read at
this point when I wrapped it up. Um,
on Saturday,
this Saturday I'll be at the Toronto Film
Festival for the Premiere of the front
runner star in Hugh Jackman,
who's already getting Oscar buzz.
Uh, it's going to be very exciting
to be a, to be that close man,
to be that close to the,
the biggest trophy out here in Hollywood.
And I ain't talking about your third wife.
There's a southern accent again.
MMM.
Yeah. It's going to be,
this is going to be cool.
I am so fucking psyched and feel so
lucky that I got to be in that movie.
Everybody knows seeing the trailer,
except everybody who listens to this,
who will now write negative shit,
hip,
all have positive things to say about it.
And um,
like I said, don't blink. If you blink,
you're gonna miss me, but you will not.
And I guarantee you will
not miss my mustache.
All right, that's it. Have a great
weekend. You can't enjoy the reads.
A little bit of music and then I'm going
to give you another 30 minutes for free.
A greatest hits from a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a month,
uh, for our Thursday earlier this year,
years ago. I have no idea. I
forget how the system works.
Don't talk to me about it.
All right, that's it. I'll
see y'all later. All right,
time for the advertising. Speak
of the devil. It's butcher box.
What's your box?
Delivers healthy 100% grass fed
and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage breed pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of
antibiotics and hormones before they're
slaughtered. Each box comes with at
least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual sized meals. Lsu,
Rafat bastard or a competitive eater.
You can choose from five different
box types. All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts
there for $20 off your first box in two
pounds of free ground brief and every
box for the rest of your life. So, uh,
for the rest of life of your
subscriptions, here's me,
that's $20 off your first box and
two pounds of fresh meat a month.
And for people who are already
butcher box subscribers,
you'll have a special deal on ground
brief and you can take advantage of by
logging into your account.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter
Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
All right, who's next? Oh, it's
him. H I. M. S. Here's a problem.
66% of their men lose their hair by age.
35 js is,
I got past 35 without that
then it was all downhill.
Thing is when you start to hair loss.
It's too
late. It's easy to keep the hair you have
than to replace the here you've lost.
Is that a hairline slowly starting
to move backward. Any bald spots yet?
How will you feel a year from now
if it's business as usual up there?
Why the guys turned to weird solutions
or do nothing when they could turn to
medicine and science.
I feel like they're insulting me here.
What hymns does is correct you correct,
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair loss
well known generic equivalents to name
brand prescriptions to help you keep your
hair. No snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements.
Prescription solution backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to for
hymns.com answer a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and compass can
prescribe you a products are shipped
directly to your door order.
Now my listeners get a trial month of
hymns for just $5 right now while supplies
last. See the website for
full details. This would,
this would cost you hundreds if you
went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Go to for himss.com/ [inaudible] that's
f o r a h I m s.com/burr for him,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr don't
end up looking like me. All right,
draft.
What'd you,
if they took me under their wing and
they got me all my fucking hair back,
how weird would that be? Uh, do it before.
It'd be weird. All right. Draft kings,
everybody.
A football returns tonight,
yet that that Dab, Buddha, Buddha,
and huge cash prizes are up for grabs
at draftkings. The leader in one week,
fantasy sports for the season opener.
Draft kings is hosting a fantasy
football context contests.
That's just $10 to enter and
has a $1 million top prize.
But for a limited time, if you
sign up with the code bird a, B,
you are our draft kings will give you
a free entry with your first deposit.
Single game show showdown
is the newest way to play.
Just draft six players
from Thursdays game.
Stay under the salary cap and see
how your team stacks up against the
competition.
Put your football knowledge to work
and you could win 1 million bucks while
watching the season opener. You don't
have to come in first to be a winner.
There are two and a half
million dollars in total prices,
which means thousands
and thousands of winners.
Download the APP or go to draft
kings.com now and use code burb.
You are to sign up and
make your first deposit.
When you do draft kings will give you a
shot at 1 million bucks this Thursday.
That's code for a,
B U R R at only at draft kings
and minimum is a $5 deposit.
Eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
All right, um, before we hit play
the audio from back in the day,
there's a little bit
of audio here from uh,
I called in a sports gambling podcast and
I gave my picks for tonight's game and
a few others over the weekend and then
we got some throwback. Enjoy the music.
Thank you guys for listening and have a
wonderful weekend. Yes, sons of bitches
[inaudible]
Bill Burr on the sports gaming podcast is
brought to you by my book. He, Daddy G,
my book,
he is the leader in online sports books.
Use the Promo Code Bill bets for a 100%
deposit bonus play when and get paid at
my bookie daddy g joining us
on the line. Bill Burr. Bill.
How excited are you that
football is officially back?
Oh, this is the greatest time
of year. It's Jagan in La.
It's starting to get colder at night.
I love it. I'm actually, I, you know,
I know there's all these new rules
and they could barely hit each other.
Oh my God, I don't see, I don't even care
if it's flag football. It's football.
I'm sorry.
Is this the best football into
Halloween and Thanksgiving?
Christmas. I love it.
Favorite time of year.
Honestly, Sean, it's the
feeling I get when I, uh, when
I give myself a little, uh,
abstinence from the old medication and
then I get to indulge again in that,
that first like sinking into the couch.
That's football for me. I'm, I'm stoked.
It's back comfort food,
baby. It is so great.
I feel like they scared us a little bit
in the a week two and week three of the
preseason. They were just
flagging everything. Any, any, uh,
guy lowers his helmet even though he's
got his head up trying to hit him right
in the chest.
They're throwing a flag and then all
of a sudden week for the preseason,
all those flags dried up. I have
a feeling when it comes. Yeah,
Thursday night we'll see.
Very few of those penalties actually
called because the refs are just as big a
fan of football as us and they know it'll
just kill the game if they do it all
the time.
I think they should.
They'll rent the rest, stop making that
call. It's the top talent to do it.
This is the deal. At some point,
if the game's going to continue,
you're just going to
have to sign a release.
If you want to play this
at a professional level,
these are the risks and
they're going to make you like,
they're probably drawing
up that contract right now.
You can never come back and
sue us. I mean, look, if, if,
if this state or the federal government
can put you in jail for like 30 years
and then realize they screwed up and the
only way they let you out as you can't
sue them. I'm sure the NFL
can draft something. Yeah.
These for these people, that belt,
they'll come up with something.
So I think the game will be okay.
Yeah. The same people who drew up
the warnings for cigarettes now,
the Philip Morris guys, they'll meet up
with the NFL, they'll figure it out. Hey,
you just got to put this warning on the
helmet. You know, we'll still be good.
Yeah, come on. It was great.
It did feel like this, uh,
this college football weekend leading
into the NFL was almost a kind of a warmup
or play baby.
Yeah.
Did you watch football?
Because football has been like,
it's just been what it's been all
about man for the last few years.
Like it's just,
it's so exciting.
And then they finally figured out not
to have all those like just a hundred
cupcake games.
You know,
like I remember back in the day when
you would gamble and like in like, uh,
September,
like Nebraska would be favored by 58
over Kent State and then they'd cover,
it was like ridiculous. Um, but now
there was smart enough where they had,
they had the Michigan Notre Dame game,
they had Lsu Miami that the Florida state
game last night. I missed all of that.
I was doing some daddy labor
day stuff with the family.
I missed that one. But, um,
I,
I absolutely,
I love college football as much as I
love pro so much to my wife's Chagrin my
entire weekend and this
weekend I'm actually in
Sacramento and then I got to go
to the Toronto Film Festival.
Uh,
so I'm missing Saturday football and
I'm flying home during the one o'clock
games. So there's going to be a lot
of Dvr and going on in my house.
Oh, that's my favorite thing.
Every season is the, uh,
really football's back already.
It's only August,
wasn't it?
Just the draft.
What happens then you've got the
combine and then you just go, hey honey,
what are the real housewives?
In the off season. Exactly.
The Bachelor is a full time sport.
Like you know the NFL should be as well.
Yeah. That, that Andy Cohen show,
that's their sports center where they
hit those women all stirred up again.
What about on this play,
which you said you're barren
and you couldn't have children.
They start yelling at each other.
It's like watching a round the horn.
Yeah, it does. It does.
It cougars in the pacing of a studio
show cause they bring up game film.
They're breaking it down. What are,
you know they have former players,
former bachelor's weighing in turning
point. Madden telestrator over there.
That's great.
That's the only way I could,
I had to like get like look at my
wife's perspective and just be like,
this is just her sports center.
And then I was able to kind of relax
and then I really look at a lot of the,
you know, it's a lot of the sports chatter
out there. It's just so ridiculous.
It's like somebody like me who's not even
connected to it. Just be, I'll tell you,
I'm really concerned about our middle
release, you know, talking baseball.
It's like,
oh,
are you somebody who never played
beyond not getting picked in gym class,
but we thing is always funny. Sean's a
big fan of doing that with the eagles.
I do enjoy the I, you know,
we're, we're going to win it
all this year. It is a way,
because if you don't win,
you get all this crap.
You guys saw that show you are blah,
blah, blah. Then all of a sudden you win.
And then the other guy's like, oh,
we're easy. They apply. You didn't play,
but what do you mean? Yeah, when I,
when I wake up Monday and eagles got
their ass kicked, I'm fucking depressed.
All right. I have to live with that.
These guys, that's just a job for them.
This is my fucking life.
So yeah, I might drop
and people give you shit
saying you guys suck.
You guys show Philly's a bunch of losers
and then all of a sudden if you win
every that, that's, that's when you know,
you want to gain. When people say, oh, we,
it's not weird. It's like, oh, we must
have something that, that you resent.
Yes, exactly. All right, well,
perfect transition bill. We, uh,
we picked up a couple of games here
to break down with you. Of course,
all the spreads come in from our
official partner in my book. He died a g,
he's that Promo code bill beds for
a hundred percent deposit bonus.
First game opening game of the season.
Atlanta falcons heading into Philadelphia
right now it's looking like eagles
minus two and a half. I think it
opened at like three and a half.
It was up to four when it sounded like
when's was playing now whence is out
foals. His name to starter. Which
way you lean in on this game.
Ah,
I, you gotta take the Eagles
at home. I know. I, you know,
they're going to be raising the flag.
Every one's going to be going nuts.
Half the crowd will be in that
little jail. They have. Um, I,
Huh. I, it's, it is, it's still the eagle.
So those should win this game, but there's
still, until they, in that second one,
this is still the still angels on earth,
but I'm going to take the
eagles at home considering, uh,
nick falls at a pedestrian 300 yards in
the Superbowl compared to Tom Brady's
500 yards and losing, which
will never be broken. Does it
again,
thank you so much for bringing this up.
I go at it with Patriots fans who say
that Brady had a better game, that false.
Now Brady had an amazing game and you
can't obviously knock Brady's play at all,
but in that particular game I would say
nick foals out played him because of the
couple of key plays foals made and the
limiting of the turnovers and Brady
obviously.
Yeah,
Sean's defensive of Nick fold is a
passion of mine and Brady obviously.
What? Well, no, and then the fumble,
that kind of turned the game at
the end in on the other side,
you've got nick foals driving down to
get a touchdown. Now. I'm not trying to,
I'm up to
Tom Brady's not a running back.
He's like shifty one years old.
If you don't block it, he gets
tackled. He had that one fumble, dirty,
true for 500 yards.
If you're really going to put that,
it was our defense defense. What's
the problem on both sides of the ball?
Catch the ball. Nick false came out
like it was a regular season game.
He wasn't nervous. Tom Brady's
Tom Brady, false offenses,
played great defense defenses
on both teams. Sucked.
Sucked. The only thing was the eagles
sucked a little less than he goes.
Basically the eagles made the only,
I think defensive play the game, you
know, it's all I'm saying. Listen,
you started this shit sitting
there congratulating you. Hey,
if you're going to say like,
but that is like like
some ESPN shit to say
somebody close to 500 yards
and they're the problem. They,
I think they're all kind of
offs. Yeah. Tom didn't have the
magic. No. I, at this point it's my,
it's probably my second favorite sport.
Watching Sean talk about how nick falls
had a better game than Tom Brady and the
, and to be clear, Tom
Brady had an amazing game.
The reason the patriots lost was because
they couldn't stop anyone on defense.
That's, that's what I'm
coming. Really what you're
bringing it full circle for us.
Nick is going to suck like he has
the rest of his career and the,
I don't think that's good,
but also like eagles couldn't
stop the patriots either.
They stopped the one fucking to do. There
was like two punts the whole game. Yeah.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
There's no talking shit about what your
defense did in that game other than we
made one play that they would like the
offense was it? It was the weirdest.
I can't watch it because
it's too still too close,
but I have to go back and watch it. It's
the weirdest fucking game. I mean that's,
that's,
that's some shit that happens that
like division three high school,
but it's like two pumps in a game.
You look like a big game.
It was really a, it was, it was bizarre.
And it started off with what's his
face is like, like, like crying,
like he's at a funeral
that Malcolm Butler.
Oh Man, what did he do? What did
he do? I guess we'll never find it.
I should've known.
I should've known when he was,
when they'd bet anytime Bella
check does that we lose.
So I remember we were playing the jets
at home and Wes Welker and made all those
feet joke about Rex Ryan.
We sat him and that Brady threw the worst
pass of his career on that screen pass
or it was just,
it was like he threw it three yard hail.
Mary went up in the air and there's
always a pick six. And uh, so anyway,
what happened, man, I bet you guys beat
somebody else because I was very happy.
I would have what I could have enjoyed
watching the eagles. Finally, when am I?
Because I don't wish longterm misery on
any sports fan other than a select few
Montreal,
Montreal Canadien fans and Yankee fence.
Everybody else.
All right, so Kramer
said, are you going with,
obviously I'm going to be on the eagles.
The key with foals is if you give him
time, if he doesn't face a pass for us,
he's going to be okay. They got Jason
Peters coming back at left tackle.
I think that'll be huge.
They get some of their weapons back.
I think they could scheme
up a decent game plan.
I think their defense will play good
against the Falcons here week one and uh,
yeah, they're raising the banners.
I think there'll be jacked for it.
I'm going on the eagles.
You guys shut down the vikings,
you know everybody,
you guys just completely
shut them down in the,
in the NFC championship game,
if I remember correctly.
So they'll be census there.
I just don't,
that was like a twilight zone game.
It was bizarre because I,
every scenario in my head going over
the game for the eagles to when it was
going to be a defensive struggle,
you know, or, or a low scoring game.
I certainly didn't see teen 13 yeah,
something like that.
That's what I was thinking and I was
shocked to see them pull it out with the,
you know, 74 points or whatever
scored. Yeah, I mean, listen,
it's tough to go against the, the, I
mean the Patriots got run up last year,
but typically the team raising the
banner, it's a good bat. You know,
the contrarian in me also likes the line,
you know,
the line move is moving the wrong way.
Nick falls did just win the Superbowl MVP.
So gotta give them the
benefit of the doubt.
But what I would say the Falcons
could have that pass rush showing.
You mentioned the past,
the rush that could be this problem.
And just out of principle,
I'll of course I'm going to fade the
eagles fan niggles. All right. Next up.
Big Game. Houston Texans at the
New England patriots right now.
Patriots six point favorite.
And uh, I'll kick things off.
I like the pats here. Lane six
against this Texans team. I mean,
one thing that's been pretty consistent
in the Brady Belicheck era is they look
good coming off a loss.
And if you look at 2012 when they lost
the Superbowl in 2008 they and even back
to the parcels and 96
they came back and uh,
they won 34 13 they want
1710 they want 41 to seven.
Like this team,
I think we'll come out with a statement
game and really put it on the text.
And so that's what I mean,
I'm not sure, I'm not trying to
be a jerk here, but how does,
how does that have anything
to do with this team?
All those on all of the personnel from
all of that, that's like, you know, they,
they, they play really good historically
in the sand when it's 70 degrees out
check I guess. Yeah, I guess, I guess
to me it's, I don't bell chicks,
the guy that just doesn't lose back
to back games and I think, listen,
little brother coming off a
Superbowl loss. Yeah. Bill O'brien,
former guy in the coaching tree. I think
he's gonna want to put it on him. I just,
this patriots team seems like they're
ready to make a statement at home against
the texts in steam.
How do you, how do you see it go?
Well, I think that Texas quarterback,
what's his name there to Sean Watson?
He's coming off the ACL.
He's going to be a nightmare.
He's going to be a nightmare
for us trying to contain him.
And the only thing I like is,
I guess they have the worst
offense of line in the league.
I think that bodes well for
us. Um, what's the spread?
Six patriots lane six at home.
Oh, they always pick the perfect
number. Dot. Yeah. They're so good.
Now what I'm gonna do,
I'm actually,
I'm actually gonna take the Texans with
the points because you have the last
year we played the Kansas City chiefs
and they came in and they, they,
they killed us it up.
So I'm going to play your game and talk
about something that happened before.
Probably doesn't matter.
I think everybody's going to
jump on the path being like, oh,
they're gonna be pissed because
you've lost the super bowl.
Everything you just said.
And then the Julio Jones,
that wasn't really your though on a sports
bar like me who have jobs and make a
couple of great catches in. Now also,
this is their revenge game. I'll forget,
they'd haven't seen her since we,
uh, came back and this, you know,
came back historically two years ago
in the Superbowl against them. So, uh,
sorry, I think you're bringing the
falcons in there for a second right there.
I have not only a plan,
I'm sorry.
Oh, good. Kramer. Which way? Which way
you lean in here? Uh, I mean, yeah,
it's Bellicheck just whoops.
On his disciples period. Yeah.
Not much to handicap to Watson would
scare me with that defense. Yeah. Um, I,
I do, I am curious to see the
offensive line, but I've just seen,
I feel like we've seen this so many times
where a t and optimistic disciple of
bill Belicheck comes in and just gets,
gets a shit pushed in. So yeah, I'm not,
I'm not fading the Patriots
Week One. Yeah, I do.
I do think bill is hitting on
something. No. Because I feel like,
and maybe this is again
just kind of a gut instinct,
but the paths kind of play
themselves in September.
They use it as an extended preseason.
Kind of trialed some stuff,
figure out some things.
And I'm still shocked that Patricia got
a head coaching job because I don't know
that defense didn't Wah, you know,
instill a lot of confidence. So that's,
that's crazy that he got that Detroit Keg.
Okay.
You liked that reminds me of when I first
moved out to la the first time in the
late nineties,
everybody out here either had a Seinfeld
or a friend's credit and that entitled
them to some sort of
show runner, like, uh,
or they would get some sort of deal
and they would pair them up like, oh,
this guy wrote on friends.
This guy wrote on Seinfeld,
I think bill Bellacheck is the
Seinfeld of writers' rooms. Yeah.
So see if you did, if you did anything,
if you will, the water boy. Yeah,
he was a water boy. Bill Belichick,
you, you don't make a lateral move,
you don't become the waterboy,
you get elevated in position.
So maybe that's why a
Patricia's,
where were you guys? I mean it's so true,
but it sounds like Patricia is just,
it sounds like people are already
Pennsylvania men as a failure.
It sounds like things aren't going well.
There's some weird dynamics going on with
that team. All right. One of the, uh,
one of the Monday night games.
There's the dual Monday night game.
Do a kick off the season,
which fuck it.
Why not the La Rams head
up to Oakland right now.
The Raiders four point home
dog bill. I'll let you, uh,
get things cause started here. How do
you, how do you see this game shaken out?
Deal at, do you like the Raiders?
What's your thoughts on John Gruden?
MMM,
I'm hoping that he doesn't
regret going back to the 24,
seven,
three 65 life of coaching when I
always feel like when coaches get into
broadcasting and there was good at that.
Good at it as is Gruten is they gotta
be sitting there going like this?
Just job as a joke.
Yeah. Compared to what?
Compared to what I used to have to do.
But I imagine he missed it.
Obviously they gained the right
amount of money. He came back,
I mean Gruden I know he's been gone for a
while, man. I mean, well, how many years?
Like almost a decade and a half. He left
like early two thousands. Am I right?
Yeah, I think it's been at least 10
years. I think we looked it up. It was,
it was before the wildcat. So to
put that in perspective, yeah.
2007.
Yeah.
So that's a long time.
And each generation of kids
is a little bit different.
And he's also rebuilding. And, uh,
I saw the thing on the Ram's head
coach where he could recall like,
you see it on real sports at
Bryant Gumbel. Like there'd
be like, Hey, a minute, 42,
week eight, third quarter,
what happened? He's like, Oh
yeah, we ran that sweep play.
Uh, the guard didn't get out,
uh, quite where we wanted him to,
but he got the job done. He has like a
photographic memory. I think that guy is,
is like, if anybody's going to
be the next generation of guys,
it's gonna be him. And, um, where he's,
where he's just taking the ram
so quickly. I just think, uh,
because gluten is just starting to put
it back together. I would take the ramps.
Okay.
Kramer, you first of all, yeah,
Make Bay comes off like somewhere between
a serial killer and rain man in that
piece. He's definitely like, well advanced
of grew and, and, and just just imagine,
I mean I have to deal with
millennials on a daily basis. John,
I cannot imagine John Gruden
dealing with millennials. I mean,
we know why he came back.
We saw it in hard knocks last year.
He still was making a playbook.
He just didn't have anyone to give it to.
He loves rock and the visors,
he's, he's cut like half the team.
I think I saw that there's, there's 31
new players on his 53 man roster. Um,
I saw a great tweet.
The Raiders decided to pay a coach $100
million and not pay their best player.
90. Uh, so many reasons that, I
mean, this is the ultimate, like,
just take the ugly dog,
right?
This is the ultimate take the ugly dog
on Monday night, but I can't do it.
I can't do it in this spot. So yeah,
I'm going to fade. I come on wheat,
we think Jay Gruden's a joke. At
least I do. He made a mistake.
He's going to realize it
quickly. My talks, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't normally like to take a kind
of road favorite here in a divisional
spot. I, I normally like to take a Monday
night home dog. Great Opportunity here.
But man,
this Raiders team isn't crazy
disarray and it just seems like th the
quarterbacks pissed off. He's upset
that they traded their best player.
It's a weird move to pull this close to
the season and the Raiders did the what,
24th ranked defense with Cleo Mack.
You trade a all time defensive player.
Now maybe this lined up working
out for them in the long run,
but I think this Rahm's office,
even though they didn't get a lot of
reps in the preseason for whatever reason
McVay maybe,
you know they use the crazy analytics
and some sports sides Gruden's using the
analytics. He openly challenges
analytics, which I Kinda,
I normally like the old school
guy approach there, but uh, yeah,
I'm looking guys also that they're moving.
Yeah,
they got half the shits and
boxes. Like I just, I just felt
yes. You look at that, you look at the
ram season that last year in St Louis.
Did Donnie go well moved out to Fisher.
It was just a complete disaster.
We just think of this, if John like
John Gruden became a caricature,
much like John Madden.
Imagine if John Madden came
back to coaching after like
15 years. No fucking way.
Yeah. I think burden. Uh, it'll
be interesting. I don't know.
I'm not that guy.
Can't coach.
I'm just saying he walked into
a hell of a situation and yeah,
he's playing these guys week one who are
just going to build on what [inaudible]
the past two seasons, how much
they've improved. I just think that,
I think they are going to keep going.
Yeah.
The rams have a lot of
momentum from last year.
Not even catching like an east coast
team playing that late kick off.
You're catching another west coast teams.
So it's not like they have no, it's,
there might be more rare.
I mean there's gonna be a lot of rams
fans right now that the bandwagon has
gotten nice and roomy. Yeah. I
think it's, I think it's just,
I don't see a lot of fans going up to,
that's also true horror picture show.
That is such a weird tradition.
You guys,
let's get her costumes on and go to the
game. The foam spike shoulder pads. Like,
Hey, I got to, hey, we're
going to go tailgate.
Let me stop off at Michael's first to
get all my face pain and Styrofoam cones.
The glue on the shoulder pads.
I'm a pirate.
Yeah.
They used to look like a biker gang.
The crowd somewhere along the line yet
starting to look like, like a musical.
Like, like, like, like for kids or
even this, even the scary things.
It looks a little friendly.
It's almost like if kiss
just became sharing section.
Yeah.
And it's like rocky horror pictures,
whatever the hell that stupid
movie meets like, uh, like meats,
like a Disney ride or something.
Like,
we can only make it so scary because we
don't this something about like when you
have the dad bod and,
and,
and foam spikes coming up.
I love that.
They think that they're
intimidating together team.
The other team literally has 300 pound
guys trying to rip their heads off.
But you're up there dressed like a
pirate and you're the one who's going to
throw 'em off iPads. Man,
you're freaking me out.
There's a lot of that. The dog
pound lot of that Ellie stuff like,
you know, your dad goes there and a
rubber mask eaten dog biscuits. It's like,
come on dad, I gotta go. I gotta go.
Cool on Monday. I have to respect
you father. Come on. Yeah,
you just helped me with my math homework.
You're not crazy. All right bill,
before we, uh, before we let you go here,
what is a, maybe it's these three games,
maybe it's a, a, another game you
feel really strongly about week one.
Can we get you to throw out a lock? You
know, we are gambling podcast. So what is,
what is bill burrs
leadpipe lock for week one?
My lead pipe lock.
All right,
this is my lock and it's not
going to be gambling related.
My lock is going to be
whatever happens this week.
Most people in sports are gonna Talk
Radio are going to act like, you know,
like say Oakland gets their ass is kicked,
all they're going to be talking about
that John Grown you make the fingers was
Jacob was he sitting on $100 million
and he's all in one worst case scenario,
one game out of first they're going to
act like every God damn thing that happens
this son Thursday, Sunday and Monday is
what's going to happen the whole year.
They do it every fucking year. When Kansas
City came out and kicked the Patriots,
as all of a sudden Kansas City was the
fucking team of the future and what
happened to them? You know, the Patriots
went back and won the AFC championship,
you know, so I mean, just
don't listen for gamblers.
Do not listen to all of the freaking
out that that they're going to be doing
when they do it. That's
just, I don't know.
They always got asked like the fucking
sky is falling or Jesus just came back
after every single game.
You know what I mean?
You look at some of the teams that
started to and Oh and then get destroyed,
missed the playoffs and that's a great,
you know,
advice especially for gamblers because
a lot of times you see one week and then
complete crazy overreactions and
we always talk about that week too.
When you're picking your games,
don't overreact to that week one.
If you had a strong feeling
or you know whatever you,
you were really high on the team,
it could just be one bad game.
Don't totally throw out your shit.
Buy Lotion Bailo
exactly. Look for the look
for that overreaction spread.
See if he can jump on that.
Tons of line value there and of
course you can head over to my book.
He died ag to take advantage of that
potential line value either week one week
to live betting prop bets. They got it all
in game way during my bookie. Dot. Agee.
Use that Promo Code Bill bets
for a 100% deposit bonus. Bill.
Appreciate you calling in man. And uh,
we'll talk to you soon. Thanks dude.
All right guys, go pass. I'll see it.
Ah,
later.
Crazy.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 23rd, 2010. How the hell are you?
What's going on?
I just got back from Portland,
Oregon actually taping this a Sunday
night cause I got a bunch of bullshit I
have to do tomorrow.
Um,
I dunno what the fuck I just got back
from Portland and I hate doing these
things Sunday night because I'm, I'm
still like jet lagged. I'm out of it.
So, uh, this is gonna be a rough
one and I'm plowing through this.
Even if it fucking sucks.
I'm not stopping it and rerecording it
like I did last week because that ended
up getting me in trouble.
That's how I started talking about
that doctor Laura Shit last week.
And I got to say for the first time,
maybe the second time ever,
I'm nominating myself as Douche bag of
the week because last week I actually
supported Dr Laura Cause I had no
fucking idea who she was. And uh,
you know, I was having a rough time
doing the podcast. I needed fodder.
Somebody send me an email,
what do you think about this?
And I watched like a ten second clip of
evidently a five minute clip and I just
thought she was imitating some something
she saw on def jam. So I was like,
well she's quoting it,
she's not calling anybody that word,
but the ban all that bullshit.
And then Jay's, oh Jesus.
The fucking emails came in
from a, I ever deadly. Uh,
for my 14 podcasts listeners.
Evidently like six of them
are African American. Um,
and uh,
yeah,
they read me the riot act in different
stages and I got admit they will fucking
write cause I didn't,
I, you know, something,
my uninformed logic is usually funny that
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about and I go off on shit and I realized
that our race probably isn't one that
you should probably do that on. I
didn't know that. She was like, uh,
like rush Limbaugh with a cunt.
I had no idea. I just, you know,
I don't know the fuck she was that she
was some soccer mom with a podcast,
you know, and she was like, all the crazy
kicked out there, fucking blah blah blah.
I had no idea. Sorry. Fucking
eggs on my face. Um, but you know,
it was funny. One guy got so
into fucking trashing me. Wait,
before I close this email,
here's something I got from a former
marine talking about that clapping for,
uh, the troops going through the
airport. He goes, as a former marine,
nothing was a bigger joke than seeing
those support. The support, the troops,
stickers talk about an empty
gesture and clapping is even lamer.
I have always fucking thought those
bumper stickers with stupid support.
The troops,
she to Sligo by that for a buck slapping
on the back of your truck or car and
then he just drive away. Well, I did
my part. Do you support the troops?
Have you looked at my bumper
sticker will. All right then. Um,
yeah, that's fucking lame. Um, he said,
and clapping is even lamer. He said,
you're on the right track. Sending
over drinks to veterans who got back,
but think bigger. How about a
program called head for heroes?
That's right.
Every,
every service member of returning from
whatever fucked up Third World Shithole
we're engaged in at the time,
gets met at the airport by some
gorgeous whore and blown in a specially
designated area.
That would be a great way of
showing the country's gratitude.
You know what? I think if you can build
a banker's out, give them $1 trillion.
I think it, you can get a couple
of fucking who is, you know,
forget about the girls who have a
fucking uniform fetish. Um, but anyways,
uh, yes, so I got fucking trashed. Um,
I took a little heat off of Mel Gibson.
I bet.
Then he heard a couple of less a fucking
hate mails last week, so I apologize.
I don't know who she is.
I'm not gonna Apologize For my stupidity,
but in the future when it's
something, you know, race-related I,
I will try to be a little more informed.
All right,
well I've got to find this fucking
email with this guy fucking trashed me.
You know, he said, uh,
[inaudible] let's see. He goes,
it starts off good. Just trashing
me, which I totally get. He goes,
just like in your bit, you did
about the Jimmy, the Greek thing.
It's best for white people to just
leave it alone. Dr. Laura May be old,
but she's aware enough to
know what happens to white
people when they say the n
word or bring up racial
supremacy theories. See,
that's the part of the
tape I didn't watch.
I showed up late to that rally,
you know, by the time I showed up,
they had already put the cross
out. You know, everybody's hoods.
They took them off. It was a hot day.
I didn't know what I was walking into.
I thought it was like a fucking, you
know, Aa meeting or something. You know,
we're all over by the table, haven't
donuts. It's my fault. I came in late. Um,
so anyways, uh, he said
the podium comes out,
so I'm surprised you defended
Dr Laura in this case.
They asked where I got a lot of them.
Surprise. You defended or can we,
cause I watched eight seconds of
the tape because I'm Maura. Um,
I don't understand why there's
any debate about racial ethnic,
why any debate about racial inequality
always comes down to comedians and def
comedy jam. I don't think it does,
but evidently a, in your world,
maybe it does. Um, I've heard
this argument before, well,
black comedians say this and that
about white people and say the n word,
why can I, is it fair for
minority comedians? [inaudible]
Pitta and all basic,
all that's all that shit? Uh, I'm
trying to get to this part here.
So then he was talking
about this documentary saw
where some comic was saying,
you know, making a joke. This is actually
a good joke where white people like,
why can't I say the n word? Uh,
and then the dude was like, Oh,
it was Chris Rock. Well, why do you even
want to say it? Right. Great fucking joke.
Totally makes sense. And then the
punchline is, I've sailed the world.
I've fucked Raquel Welch.
If I could just say the n word,
my life would be complete. And then
this dude writes after that, he goes,
I think that it bothers white people
because you're not used to being told that
you can't do something white people used
to be able to do and say anything they
wanted.
Now there's all these rules.
Isn't that fucking that,
that part of the email,
that's where it just went off the fucking
rails for me. You know what I mean?
It's like I totally get it.
She's a fucking idiot.
I didn't realize it because I watched
that short little clip, you know,
I shouldn't have support that shit.
And, and you're offended by that,
which I totally get. And then
in the end, you make some dumb,
general generalization about white people.
See where all the same,
we're fucking morons.
Jesus Christ.
I've sailed the world. Fuck walk. Hell,
we'll see. That part's the joke. But this,
here's what he writes bothers white
people that you're not being used to told,
being told that you can't
do something. Oh yeah, yeah.
We just run around doing whatever the
fuck we want to do. It's great. Ah,
Jesus Christ. That's, that's
one the great stereotypes
is that we're all Kennedy's living on
fucking Martha's vineyard rather than
fucking
okay.
You know, the majority of
white people aren't out there.
Majority of white people sitting
in cubicles not living their dream,
drowning in a sea of fucking debt,
trying to get health insurance.
Isn't that the majority of fucking
white people? Evidently not.
Evidently according to this guy,
white people have yachts
sailing the world. All 300
million of us, you know,
do you just see it during that, the Gulf
War, uh, the Gulf spill there, you know,
that was one of the biggest problem.
All those white people,
all the 300 million white people with
our fucking yet just sailing around. Oh,
it's so awesome to be white. You can
just walk them. You can do what it say,
whatever you want to do.
It's fucking incredible.
Um, that's an argument I've, I've
gotten it to, uh, with the, um,
I think every fucking,
yeah.
Female comics, black comics, every fight.
They just go, yeah, it's easy for you.
All you gotta do is show up,
man. Oh yeah, that's all it is.
I don't even audition. I just lay here and
they, they call me up and I'm like, why?
Why did you give me that part then?
Cause your white, here you go.
You don't have to work
for shit. Uh, you know,
that's that classes. You know that, that
fucking double standard right there. Okay,
now we're opening a whole
nother can of worms.
Let's talk race for the next
couple of weeks. People.
This ought to bring out a lot of ugliness.
Um, that's that classic fucking like,
that's one of those statements like you,
if you flip that thing,
what you just said there,
that generalization that you made of,
of white people that basically what
we just sit around and they do.
People just give a shit and we can
do whatever the fuck we want to do.
You basically going to define
us by the Illuminati. MMM.
If you flip that around and somebody white
says that upon another race of people,
then there were in like a Mel
Gibson situation. All right,
now I'm open this up for discussion.
I'm not opening this up for
fucking rednecks to come
on here and be like, yeah,
that's why the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm not saying it like that,
but what I'm saying, you know
what? This is what I've learned.
Traveling the fucking
Globe and by the globe.
I mean I went to two other continents.
I went to Australia and Europe.
I did all my research with just white
people. All right. A. Dot. Yeah.
I think pretty much people
are people. We're all the
same. You know, there's a few,
like very small percentage of people on
this planet are genuinely good people
and everybody else is
pretty much full of shit.
And everybody looks at everybody
else and I think they got it easier.
And all you gotta do is,
yeah, you gotta do is this,
I got to work twice as hard at this guy
and this guy does this. And you know,
no one wants to know
what I've learned.
Well,
you probably don't wanna know
because I'm a fucking moron,
but for what it's worth,
this is what I've learned.
Life is that life isn't fair.
It's really fucking difficult.
But if you bust your ass,
you're going to make it on whatever
level you're going to fucking make it.
You surround yourself with positive
people and you don't fucking quit when
somebody kicks you in the fucking chest,
you get back up again.
You don't walk right into his foot.
You go around finding
different fucking avenue,
or maybe you build your own avenue,
you do whatever you're gonna fucking do.
And everybody's got different
starting positions and all that shit,
and it isn't fucking fair. And there's
nothing you can fucking do about it. But,
uh, you know, and there's some people who
don't get stuff because of who they are
because they're, they're, they're so that,
that they're fat or that they're fucking
in an Asian guy with one leg. Okay.
And he can't work at a Goddamn fucking
place where you get a fake Tan, you know?
Yeah. That shit definitely fucking exists.
But you know, what are you gonna do?
You know?
But you know what?
I think most people don't make it because
they're fucking pussies and they just
tap out, you know? And I'm
talking about fucking wipe.
I'm actually talking mostly white people
cause that's what I know, you know?
And I got, I got people, people I know,
they just fucking quit and they've got
all these fucking excuses why they can't
fucking do it. And it's
like, no, you, you quit,
you got punched once in the face and
then you just fucking laid down and now
you're going to fucking
blame everybody else. Right.
Did that make any fucking sense?
I'm trying to say something positive here.
Trying to be balanced where it's like,
I know you and like female comics are
always fucking complaining, but you know,
I can't tell you the amount
of fucking times I would.
I would be auditioning for festivals and
the industry becoming up to me going,
we need funny women.
Where are the funny women?
And then they would pick a fucking
woman just cause they needed one.
Not because they were one of
the funnier fucking people.
I'm not saying that female comics
aren't funny, but I'm just saying there.
There are examples. You know what?
You guys can all go fuck yourself.
I'm a balding redhead trying to get
into movies, all right? You know,
cry me a fucking river. I
don't give a shit, all right?
But I was wrong about the
doctor Laura thing. Okay?
When I start a fucking group crying
about how there's no fucking redheaded
action heroes out there. You know Jesus
Christ. What's that fucking movie?
That's the number one
movie in the country.
They got 58 fucking action stars in there.
One of them can't be a redhead.
Couldn't have called up David Caruso to
show his pasty white ass walking up to
Arnold Schwartzenegger. Ah,
it gives a fuck. All right.
So there you go. That was,
that was my,
that was my roundabout apology.
Uh, no, seriously. I
really felt bad about that.
Felt like an ignorant ass at a rather
than just immediately come on and
apologize.
I left it up there for the week,
so I'd get my nice pounding from everybody
and uh, yeah. You know what I mean?
I fuck around and said a lot of
fucked up shit, but I, you know,
I'm trying to start your week off right.
I'm not trying to Piss you off,
although there's probably a lot of women
out there who had fucking disagree,
but you know, it's comedy. You
know, people, people get hurt.
It's out fucking works.
This is the worst apology ever,
but it's coming from the heart.
All rights. Go Fuck Yourself.
That's how we got to end it. All
right. I grew up with no hugs,
so if I'm trying to be fucking nice,
it has to end with go fuck yourself.
Um, speaking of go fuck yourself.
Um, I just got back from Portland,
Oregon and I had a great time
up at the a helium comedy club,
the grand opening helium comedy club,
and a Portland,
Oregon is a city that I
have not worked in, um,
in 10 years because there was no comedy
club for a guy in my situation to come
in there and work. Uh, I did work.
There was a local club there, but it
wasn't really a comedy club. It was,
but it wasn't like the club owners
is basically what he would do.
He would paper the room,
which is a, the showbiz term.
He would just just call people up.
And I talk about this last week I came
fucking remember he would just call
people up and just say,
you know,
or have this whole team of telemarketers
call up people and tell them that they
want a comedy show.
And he would just call enough people
where he would fill up his room every
fucking night of the week from Tuesday
through Sunday. And everybody cared.
It got in for free.
And then all he did was fucking just
throw food and drinks down their fucking
throats. And that's how he makes
his million. But meanwhile,
the comedian stands on stage in front
of a bunch of fucking drunk overeaten
jackasses who could give
a fuck about the show.
And you had to go up there on a Tuesday
night with a goddamn whipping a chair,
two shows, Friday, three
shows, Saturday the guy would,
he wouldn't even let you
talk to the waitstaff,
you'd think if you put a
comedian through that bullshit,
they can at least try to get fucking leg,
you know,
try to get a little bit of action.
He fucking cock block young
like nine different levels.
It's a fucking horrific gig
is what I'm telling you.
And then the second you got a
TV credit and you said, hey,
can I have an extra quarter?
The next time I fly across the country?
And then the guy that you just wouldn't
return your phone call. So he basically,
other than up and coming guys would
just be booking horrific talents.
So Portland has been really starved
for any sort of national headlines.
So now there's a new club out there and
I was really excited to be the first guy
to come to town and, uh,
and have, uh, you know,
work the comedy club.
And I had no idea how bad that other
club was until I talked to some of the
younger comics. This guy told me,
he walked in there to do a spot.
He moved up from,
uh,
from host to feature in that club owner.
Guy Calls him and he's like, look,
I make $1 million a
year just selling food.
That's what he said.
When you get on stage,
no f bombs that just reads them the
fucking riot act. It's, it was horrible.
It's a great business model.
He's made his money,
but it's fucking horrible for
the development of Comedians.
He's sitting on their fucking chest.
Okay.
And that Dick's, he's not even letting
them get fucking lay. What did they,
you know, just asshole
fucking asshole. Um,
so it's great that there's a new comedy
club out there and that the, you know,
there's another place for these comics
to work and that they can actually see
national headlines.
Cause that was a fucking big thrill for
me when I was back in Boston. So, uh,
so if you live in the Portland area,
you know, if you're a lumberjack,
climbed down out of the fucking tree and
come on down, do a helium comedy club.
It's a great club. And uh, he's
got C's. Who's he got next week?
He's got a
Jimmy Pardot
is who he's got Jimmy Pardot. Uh, right.
Is that what is what I think
there was one other person, um,
oh, Reggie watts. Reggie
rots on Wednesday.
And then Jimmy Pardot from the never
not funny podcast. Jesus Christ.
I'm losing my God damn memory.
I knew there was somebody else.
So go check out those
shows next week and uh,
support a comedy club that actually
will book somebody who's funny and on
television. All right, low
plowing ahead here. Um,
what's the next thing on the docket? I
really have, I don't have shit this week.
Do I? What am I? 17
minutes in? That's not bad.
You gonna fucking tap out
at 40 minutes yet. You know,
you guys don't go home early every once
in awhile and just fake a fucking injury
at work. Try to pretend like a
forklift drove over here. Some shit.
You know what I really wanted to do
was I wanted to look up that five hour
energy here on the Internet,
five hour energy.
Now this is how I do my research now.
Five hour energy I think is a liquid
cocaine and I think it really fucks with
you yet. I think it's bad. So, um,
rather than just look up five
hour energy consumer reports,
I'm going to search five
hour energy unhealthy. See,
and this is how most people do research.
They already have their mind made up
and then they just read shit that agrees
with them. Yeah. You know,
according to a fuck face.com um,
I'm exactly right.
Side effects of five hour energy drink
shots. Are they unhealthily unhealthy?
Let's read this one. This is the first one
that came up. Side effects of fiber to,
okay.
I was at lunch today and my friend was
trying to get someone to drink five hour
energy caffeine shot.
So I,
I opened it and smelled it and
said I'd give it a shot anyways,
I think you're supposed to mix them in
a drink. But I straight shrugs that,
chugged it and almost gagged from
the taste. After I swallowed it,
it took me like 15 minutes to get that
horrible taste. Uh, out of my mouth.
I tried eating food,
chewing gum, drinking,
but the taste stayed in my mouth
for like 40 minutes. I felt sick.
Every time I thought about the taste, I
think the taste bothered me so much. Uh,
Jesus,
why you do or you're going to get to the
part where you had the heart attack so
I can feel like I'm right.
Take the taste,
bothered me so much caffeine.
But anyways, I'm shy.
So after the tastes and
the sickness wore off,
I was feeling great all day and I felt
probably the happiest I have all school
year because all my subtle tendencies
wore off and I acted more outgoing and
funny like I do around friends.
They just turn this dude
into a fucking coke head.
That's classic reason why people
do drugs. Helps me loosen up, man.
I could talk to the chicks.
Um,
there's nothing on here.
Are you shitting me?
Oh, gives a fuck. I just, you know,
why don't you get eight hours sleep? Why
don't you do, why did you start that?
You know,
I had somebody else in another mother
call in or call in or write in going back
to that fucking that shit I said about
stay at home moms and once again they
were doing, she was, she was saying, I
totally agree with you. I understand.
You're absolutely right.
They have no right to be saying
it's the most difficult job ever.
And then she wrote three paragraphs about
how difficult it is to be a mother and
to be worrying up and having the
responsibility of another life.
And it's like I like, I don't, I get it.
I know I don't totally get it cause
I don't have a kid. But you know
enough already.
All right.
Like that other listeners said you
chose to be a mother. You know,
you're acting like a, all of a sudden
you've got like a fucking terminal disease
and all you're doing is bringing up
the bad shit. What about when you have,
you have a bad day and you come
home and that kid with, you know,
all that innocent just looks at you and
just thanks. You're bigger than life.
What about that? Doesn't
that, that, that, you know,
wash away some of the spittle
on your shoulder blade?
I don't fucking know. You know,
it's funny, actually ironic. It was,
I was just watching 60 minutes and they
have one of those guys on the fucking BP
oil rig and I said when
they jumped off of it,
it was the equivalent of jumping off
a three story fucking brownstone.
Evidently it's the equivalent of
jumping off a 10 story fucking building.
That's what they did.
That was their choice standing there
in the middle of the Goddamn Ocean.
Either I burn up or I jump into
the fucking oily water without, oh,
it was brutal. Okay, so while
you mom's stand the fuck down,
stop giving me shit.
I was just fucking joking around.
I'm just gonna have to end up
apologizing to everybody here. You know,
I had somebody run into me today from a
New Zealand just podcast is really going
to be random.
Somebody wrote it from a New Zealand.
I was thinking about this topic that for
people and all these random countries
who listened to this podcast,
I'm going to start nominating who I think
the coolest person from your countries
and with new New Zealand, I
think it's a no brainer. It's
Phil Rudd.
You don't get any cooler than that guy.
He's played the exact same drum beat for
fucking 35 years and he's such a tough
bastard that no one has the balls
to tell them to switch it up.
Yeah.
You don't feel like, how about boom,
check, boom, check, check. You know,
how about that
fucking guy?
The whole fucking,
the whole goddamn album.
I think he just goes in there right and
he just starts fucking play in that beat
and then they just,
they just play the whole song,
the whole fucking album worth of songs.
And then when they're done they just,
they just started yet fail,
fail.
It's over. We're done. Yeah.
We made another album. He just
said, oh, all right. Yeah,
let's just start breaking down
his kit. Oh, Geez. I got nothing.
I really riffing about Phil Rudd.
There was some of the wars beatbox and
you're ever gonna fucking here. Um, oh,
here we go. You know what? I got to read
this right here. Now I've got something.
This will take up a good three fucking
minutes. You know what? I liked it.
This podcast is this difficult. Now
you guys can relate to me. You know,
you sitting there and you Goddamn
cubicles on a fucking Monday.
Unless you're white. Of course
you're out on your yacht. You know,
chatting it up with a Kennedy. Hey, when's
the stock market going to crash again?
Give me the heads up.
Don't tell the Puerto Ricans.
That's what it's like.
That's exactly what it's like.
There's not white people working farms,
slaves to corporations.
Ah, not at all. Not at all. All your
deal. You, you don't even have to get up.
You don't have to get up.
I spent nine years in bed just because
I was white and they just fucking
hilarious.
I made more money then than when I worked.
That's how great it is to be white.
It's so fucking easy.
And thank God for people who aren't white,
who've never been white to tell
me what it's like to be white.
It's fucking awesome.
Let me tell you something about being
white white guy. This is how good it is.
Oh yeah.
What do you reincarnated was
your name frank and another life?
Um, is that a white guy name? I don't
fucking know. All right. So anyway,
so I've pissed off a bunch of
people and uh, I just want to,
I just want to try to redeem myself and
show you that it's not all bad either.
It's not all bad. You know, I do inspire
some people. Uh, here's one for you.
Milk white thighs is the name of this.
This email,
somebody sent me a set bill. A
few things. The last five years,
I've been six feet tall,
240 pounds.
Upon trying to work out with
no results and no willpower,
I usually lose five pounds,
give up and sit and eat shit.
However,
you talked on the podcast a few weeks
ago about Bill Clinton and Al sloshing
around the White House.
I believe I said sashaying around the
White House with their milky white hips.
Um, I was in a quiet room with
about 50 people and blurted, blurt,
laughed out loud, laughed
loudly, blurt laughed loudly.
That's really worded strangely. You
burst out laughing. There we go.
Ever since then. How will
it be sitting, watching TV,
looking at my treadmill
and I will say to myself,
slosh your ass up there and work off those
milky white hips or something to that
effect. It makes me laugh every time
and realize how pathetic I've been.
It's been about three weeks of this
everyday and 45 minutes on the treadmill.
I'm down to 208 pounds.
Well,
on my way to my goal of
a hub of a buck 80 also,
I'm a dude and my name is Lindsey.
I know you don't have a
lot of female listeners,
so if you ever feel like you need a
quote or just a woman's approval on
something, you do, feel free
to use my name and just say,
yeah, this chick Lindsay,
I know this chick,
Lindsay who takes it. Uh,
I'm more than willing to compromise my
sexuality for the furthering of your
career.
Um,
I would buy five of anything
bill Burroughs endorsing.
All right. There you go.
There's a good email. Congratulations.
You're down to 208. Keep going.
And, uh, I'm glad. You know,
I'm glad I just didn't bring all
negativity to the podcast this past week.
I felt fucking horrible about that even
though I've been kind of a cost again
this week. That's what I do. You
know, you came back, didn't you?
You know, I don't know any better.
I'm just a white guy laying in bed.
I can't remember the last time
I've had disappointment in my life.
It just doesn't happen. Just
doesn't happen, you know, you know,
sometimes the sale on my schooner
will break and I'm just like, AH,
Jesus Christ. And then I call the
government and I say, Hey, can you uh,
can you send me another one? They're like
white and what color are you? I said,
why they guy? There you
go. Right on the way.
You know, I agree with the first half of
the email. This guy I'm making fun of,
but I would love to send this guy
my fucking taxes. I really would.
These motherfuckers,
what a lot of people don't realize is
that rich people feel there's enough rich
people and they got all kinds of fucking,
they take a fucking pipe to a
goddamn knees every fucking quarter.
They make sure they can only be,
they can only be a certain number or
a fucking rich people unless you just
invent some shit. Like,
uh, I dunno. I Dunno what
if you come up with the technology
for the fucking iPod then even then,
I mean they'll just, they'll just hire
you on as like a scientist. Right.
I'm really getting to know over my
fucking head here. You know what I mean?
If you come up with Facebook,
if you that.
I think that's the way now that you
can actually become fucking rich,
but I'll tell you right now, it's not
fucking telling jokes. Fucking assholes.
Yeah.
Fucking assholes.
God Damn fucking quarter.
I gotta I gotta. Oh Gee, I
am. I am going to get into it.
I'm not going to fucking get it.
Just give me some me so fucking mad.
You're telling me I think I'm
getting ahead. Look at me. Yeah,
I'm getting the hey fucking sit down.
That's what they do every quarter.
You sit the fuck down.
You stay right where you're at bay.
Sit right where you're at.
That's what it is. Anybody else?
This isn't even a color thing.
Anybody else in the fucking middle class.
There you go.
Fucking rich pricks
fucking last goddamn eight years or
they're making a ton of fucking money and
then all of a sudden the shit hits the
fan and they run out of the Goddamn
restaurant. Leave everybody
else with the fucking check.
Yeah.
Fucking unbelievable.
My ever going to get that fucking car.
I'll tell you,
I got off the plane today and somebody
had the dodge challenger in the all white,
like the vanishing point guys ever
see that movie with that dude?
Kuwalski he's got an all white charger.
So they did this tribute to,
it's all fucking white and the guy
had these fucking rims on it and uh,
yeah,
I just sat there drooling at my
girl's looking at me like, she's like,
Jesus Christ, you were obsessed
with that car. It's like, yeah,
you know I am.
Yeah.
Well, you know, I'm standing
here. You just got off the plane.
You could say hello to me,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh, you know what that reminds me of. I
fucking went to go to this pizza place.
I really try to do fun things when I
was in Portland, try to be healthy.
I went for a fucking hike. I was
sticking with my smoothies, you know,
dropping pounds here and uh,
yeah.
Anyway, somebody tells me that in, in
Portland they have this fucking room.
They got this pizza parlor where they
had the best God damn pizza and all the
fucking northwest. So this guy has
like this homemade goddamn doe,
and he only makes so much of it every day.
And when he's done making the dough,
he's done making pizza. Go
Fuck Yourself. All right?
So I'm like, you know, well shit, I gotta
try this pizza. So I go on the Internet,
I look up, I see where it is.
It's right on Hawthorne Street,
like 45th and Hawthorne, 46 in Hawthorne,
something like that, right? So I'm like,
all right, I gotta go check this
fucking thing out. So I allow,
I get myself an hour and a half
before the show to get there,
to get a God damn pizza, right? It's
a fucking pizza. Okay. So I call up,
just told me to cut, just
to call this place. And uh,
I called up the,
it rings like 11,
12 fucking times and nobody picks up.
So my guy,
you know what? They're probably
busy. No big deal. I got an hour.
I'll get there with an hour and a half
before, right? I get a goddamn cab.
I'm driving over there. Cab driver
goes out. Just to let you know,
this guy's kind of like the
pizza Nazis, like, like the,
like the fucking a soup Nazi on Seinfeld.
So I show up and I walk in. Lo
and behold, the place is packed,
but I see this little two top gets up,
waitresses cleaning off the table,
she walks away. So I go over and I
sit down, get re order the pizza,
I'm checking out where people are ordering
of getting excited is what I'm trying
to tell you. And then the waitress
comes over, she's like, um,
were you over in the waiting room next
door or did you just like walk in here
and sit down? And I was like, um, I
just came in and sat down. She goes,
yeah, I'm, you have to like
fight in, um, next door.
You know, those people, everything's,
everything's a question you
have to like sign in next door.
And I'm like, oh, all right. I go, well,
how long is the wait? She's like, well,
I can't really like say it's, you
know, it's kind of busy at that point.
He's like a quarter of, I go, well,
I gotta show at eight to quarter to
7:00 AM I going to have time to order a
pizza and eat it? She's like, yeah, no,
now.
And um,
and then that's when my blood starts
fucking boiling because I realized what I
just walked into.
You know what I walked into?
I walked into the pizza version of pinks,
hotdogs out here in fucking La,
the pizza version of Magnolia Bakery
in New York City or that fucking place.
We get the hot dogs in Chicago,
you know,
hour and 15 minutes to make a
fucking pizza. You can't do that.
This guy sitting here acting like,
you know,
like he's making some sort of gourmet
for now. I'll tell you right now,
that's my overrated for the fucking week.
Standing in line at any restaurant.
These, you know, the, the, the
breakfast place in your neighborhood,
your girlfriend's like,
oh my God,
the stuffed French toast is to die for
and you stand there and fucking line,
never worth it. It's never
worth the hype. Okay?
You learn anything from this podcast
other than I'm an ignorant asshole.
Don't ever stand in line for
fucking food. Okay? And less some,
there's a natural disaster.
The places flooded in this.
They're scooping out fucking pea soup.
You know when you're putting
it into your baseball hat,
then you'll stand in line. Soup
kitchen. You stand in line,
but don't stand outside these fucking
places. It's stupid. It's never worth it.
You know fancy restaurants. You
don't stand outside. You call up,
you make a fucking reservation.
But I'm not standing out there
like I'm waiting to fucking
okay.
Do they even make goddamn sense?
You know what I mean?
He's fucking people in New
York. They stand outside for
90 minutes for a cupcake,
for fucking cupcake.
It's gone in three seconds.
You know it's going to Piss me off.
Is some people in Portland. Okay.
They're actually going to figure out
what pizza parlor I'm talking about and
then they're going to tile. Tell me, dude,
it's totally fucking worth at
these low self esteem Douche bags
who just allow themselves to get totally
treated like absolute fucking shit for
pizza. Yeah. Sorry,
I can't make you a pizza within an hour
and 15 minutes. Well, you know what?
Fuck you and your fucking pizza.
What do you think about that and
your number one God damn rating.
I've got a pizza hut.
Eat their fucking slop.
You got to kill him. He is that. I
know. I'm going to have to go back.
I have to try it.
People hyped it so much.
That's what I'm really mad about is I
know as much as I just fucking talked
about that shit,
I'm going to have to go back down and go
get it and for all you guys wondering,
yelled at Magnolia. It's, it's a great
cupcake, but it's not that great.
It's not that great to have to stand there
and listen to that awful conversation.
Now,
if people driving by looking at you,
trying to figure out what are
they standing in line for sure.
You know
it's the president.
They're doing a book signing.
Is there a porn star there was going
to blow you at the front of the line.
Can I raise the stakes for something
funny within the last seven minutes?
All right. Fuck this. Fuck
this podcast. Here we go.
Why don't I nominate some youtube
videos for the week? Everyone. Um,
I have a ton of them and I'm going to
make the bold rex Ryan statement that I
think pretty God damn soon,
if not already,
the Mlm podcast.com is going to have the
best fucking youtube video collection
of youtube videos. All right. I mean,
cause you guys are on the cutting edge.
A lot of these videos that you guys
send me, they only got like, you know,
10,000 to 40,000 fucking hit.
Some of them have like a hundred thousand
or so like that and even a few with a
million. But if they're really
funny, I don't give a shit,
but I think that we're on the
cutting edge of some shit.
Like here's two that I found
that, you know, only, you know,
in the tens of thousands of hits. So
I'm assuming you haven't seen them. Uh,
look up a prank of the century.
This woman puts on a mask and scares
the shit out of this other woman and,
and it's, you gotta watch it, it's
fucking great. And then piss off
pissed off. Cat freaks
out. Look up that one.
And we got a lot of people.
You guys like violent shit.
I'm trying to categorize them now.
And by the way,
the MM podcast is the official fan page.
There's the Monday morning podcasts.
If you don't have to,
you know,
it's a pain in the ass to go on youtube
and try to find six different videos,
right? Typing it in and all
that shit. You're going to
get caught. You're at work,
you're not supposed to be doing it.
But if he just subtly type in the MLM,
podcast.com and nobody fucking looking,
all of them are going to be right there.
And you can watch one after another,
you know,
or you can make it last
the whole fucking day.
You can even drink that five hour fucking
energy and just start screaming at
your screen if you want. It's all
up to you. Um, so anyways, uh,
here's a couple of for you fight
fans out here. I will start slow,
look up a choke slam.
Um,
I hope that's the name
of the fucking video.
This is referee reffing a
fight in this choke slam.
Look it up. All right. Um,
here's kind of a cute one. Says little
girl boxer. It's actually a boy.
His name's pretty boy. Bam, Bam. And
you've got to look at this fucking kid.
This kid would kick the shit.
Just imagine this kid fighting
another fifth grader. Um,
and this is the most insane one.
Boston Street fight guy with bat does
damage Boston Street fight guy with bat as
in baseball bat does damage.
Um,
what else do we got? Summer
discourteous, something ridiculous.
Swollen in south Philly.
It's a guy walking around like he's got
a fucking hard on having conversations
with people. Sort of an old
bit. I've seen it done before,
but this guy does a
great, um, wrestling fans.
We got two for you are much
your man on Coke and uh,
ultimate warriors. Confession
is absolutely fucking brilliant.
You got to look at that one. And uh, Oh,
more violence office worker goes
insane. Second Angle. Never.
Natalie, there's some new
footage. Uh, what else?
Oh, this is a great one.
Look up the turtle, man. This
one might be my favorite.
This guy's missing all these front teeth.
And when you find out how
he's missing his teeth,
it's just one of the great stories
that he just alludes to it.
It's fucking awesome. It's just this
redneck who just fucking catches turtles.
And, uh, I, I swear to God,
I would pay admission to sit on the
side of the pond and just watch this guy
catching turtles. It's fucking hilarious.
And I actually getting into covers,
we were talking about the worst
covers of all time. Here's a great,
one of the best covers I've ever
seen just as far as being creative.
Look up a stairway to heaven, the
Beatniks, that's all one word, B,
e. A. T. N. I. X. It's fucking cool
as hell. It's really fucking cool.
They do stairway to heaven the way the
Beatles would do it. It's really fucking,
I dunno, it's really creative. Um,
and speaking of movies,
here's one for you is, uh,
I got in this conversation
with somebody on the Internet.
They sent me an email and they were
talking about how, uh, you know,
they're not married yet,
so they're kind of hanging out with people
who are younger than them so they get
a little bummed out when they make
references to movies that nobody's seen
before. So, uh, he started
showing him some of the classics,
like the dirty dozen and that type
of shit. And he asked me, you know,
what are some of the great fucking movies,
uh,
I should recommend with then let it
to like music and that type of shit.
And uh, here's a new topic for
is do you guys have like songs?
You must have these, these fucking
songs that the second you hear him,
you can't hear the song without thinking
of the movie. You know what I mean?
Cause you do here, I'll give you
a classic fucking example and uh,
I think even the broads will know
this one. Did I get rid of it?
I had it all fucking cued up.
I really am the worst.
Can I ever do this?
This is why I started off in fucking
radio and then my career quickly ended
because I would do the whole beginning.
You're listening to 6:40 AM
WEC be a broadcast service.
The fucking whatever the fuck I
used to say. Hang on a second.
Let me get to youtube.
God dammit bill.
Okay.
And now there's a lull. See what happens.
You know what? I'll play the other one.
Well, no, I can't do that at the end.
And ability to do that shit. All right,
let me set the mic down. Hang
on a second. All right. Do you,
why don't you act like you're
working for once. All right,
now I'm yelling at you
because I fucked up.
What the hell's the name
of that fucking Saba.
Oh yeah.
Something. Something, something.
Something. Um, air. It is. I got it.
Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Oh,
you fucking condo. Come on. Come up.
Yeah.
Should I edit this out?
You know what this is
like is when you fucking,
someone just told you what their name
is and then somebody you know comes
walking in and you go to introduce them
and you have no fucking idea who they
are. That's how I'm speaking
right now. All right. What,
what movie does this remind you of?
Instantly?
Come on.
You know what? You know the movie,
right? I know. Most of you know though.
Even the broads, we'll get
it. Come on. You know this.
I'll wait for the breakdown.
I'll wait for the breakdown of it.
Where the hell is it?
Where the hell was it?
I had this whole fucking thing queued up.
This part right here.
You don't remember this
[inaudible]
I haven't did the sound effects.
Remember that reservoir dogs,
when he cuts the fucking dude's ear off.
I used to love that God damn song and I
couldn't listen to it for 10 years cause
every time I fucking heard it,
I just thought about Marvin Nash
getting his Goddamn ear cut off.
God. Stop. Stop yelling at him.
Fucking what a,
what a great piece of acting
by both of those guys who ever played
Marvin Nash and, uh, Mister Blonde.
I can never remember people's
fucking names. Yeah, we'll
call him Vince Gilligan,
I dunno is fucking date. And I want to
fuck that. I forget his name. You know,
most guys to play psycho would
act like a fucking psycho.
How they think a psycho supposed to act,
you know, and just how fucking Cami was.
You know, that's what's really fucking
scary. Somebody cut in your ear,
I've gone and act like a fucking maniac.
You'd almost start laughing
halfway through it. Like,
is this guy mocking being crazy? But
it's the calmness with which he does it.
Here's another one for you.
These are really easy for like guy movie.
So I need some more, more suggestions.
I'm actually going to disguise this one.
I downloaded this song because of the
movie and I didn't realize that this
fucking Irish dude babbles telling some
fucking story for 20 minutes before they
get to the part that I
actually recognized. Uh,
let's see if you can guess this
one. Here we go. What movie
goes to where
the does with Joyce and lettuce,
right? You're like, what the fuck is this?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I didn't,
I didn't want to get blood on the floor.
[inaudible]
mine,
you know it.
[inaudible]
hello audio.
Tion
that's a Donovan singing a Atlantis.
That was from a,
the Billy bad scene.
When they start kicking the shit.
Fucking Billy bet.
Is there anything better than that fucking
camera angle when they're doing that?
Pointing up at Robert De Niro's character.
Jimmy just fucking kicking him.
Rick flair. Couldn't do fake kicks
better than Robert Dinero. You know,
he just sitting there kicking him.
See,
this was bad.
Billy batts was a made guy with
some real grease balls. Shit.
We did what we wanted.
We were wise guys. Right?
What's the last one I got here? So
I, I, you know, as usual, you know,
whenever people ask you these questions,
I can't end up, I can't remember them.
Um, let's see. Here's one for you.
This is actually an interesting
one that's really fucking upset.
This is one from a movie that the dude
ended up selling. This is from cool hand,
Luke. All right, for those of
you have seen cool hand Luke,
if you haven't seen cool hand Luke,
you've got to fucking watch that movie.
All right. And basically the guy who
did the score, uh, wrote this song.
There's a scene where they
have to tar this road and, uh,
Paul Newman's character,
you know,
rather than just sitting there being like,
this is a miserable fucking job.
He gets them all amped up that it's
supposed to take all fucking day,
but he gets these guys so fucking
amped up. They just, they just fucking,
they just, it's like they took
five hour energy and before they,
they're just flying down the fucking
road and they're all laughing,
having a great fucking time.
And they finished the road and they
actually have an afternoon off. Right?
So it was like Paul Newman's way
of saying fuck you to the, to the,
to the, to the screws. Is that what
they called them back down to the,
to the guards. Right. So they
had to have this music. So they,
this guy wrote this score for this scene.
Uh,
but the problem was it
was perfect for the movie,
but the problem was years later he sold
it or I don't know how far along he sold
it and it got played so much in this
other shit that it actually kind of fucks
up the movie. This is, this is the score.
This is going to be for some older
people to actually understand this is the
music that they had for the ta.
It's called tar sequence. When they,
when they tar the road
and they ended up selling,
the guy ended up selling
the song for something else.
Here it is just listening to this shit.
Ah,
you suck. God dammit. Fuck the, see.
This is why I got out of rain.
I used to do shit like that on the air.
That would be the worst break ever.
I am the fucking worst.
I want a great intro. I gave
that song. All right, here we go.
Yeah,
this is the tar in the road.
Totally makes sense.
Florida.
Good evening and welcome to the six
o'clock news. It was a four car accident.
The mother fuckers sold it to
every six o'clock news station.
This was the classic with
you fucking old like me.
Anytime the fucking news came on,
this is the fucking song that they played.
This is back when,
when they actually had fucking journalists
telling you what the corporations
wanted you to know.
[inaudible]
good evening. I'm Jake Johansen.
Why did I say Jay? I'm a your,
I was, that's how fucked up my brain is.
I was trying to think, uh, Chet Curtis.
I was like, well, I can't say I can't
say Chet. That's an actual fucking name.
I don't name names. So then
I'll go, I'll go with Jake.
And then for some reason I don't,
it just got crossed up and I said,
Jake Johann's I gave Jake,
Joe answered a fucking shout out the best
God Damn Comedians the last fucking 20
years from my money.
Yeah.
So anyways, yeah, it's called
out of the tar sequence.
So that one actually doesn't remind
me of the, the, the, the fuck.
That's a reverse one.
I actually watched the movie
and I'm getting into that scene.
And then I think there's like all of a
sudden I'm going to start listening to
the news. So Jesus Christ, that was,
that was probably the worst debut
of any segment. But you knew,
you got to admit you were
definitely into it, right?
I know you guys have suggestions.
Can you help me out? All right.
I'm fucking burned out with this fucking
podcast trying to get ready to do other
shit and I'm just, you know, look at
me. I'm fucking supporting Nazis now.
Is that what I'm doing? Is that I'll
fucking tired. I am doctor Laura.
You're not a bad birthday. Fucking
moron. All right. Here's one for you.
You know what?
I'm going to actually do one.
I'm going to do one here for it to try
to make peace after my doctor Laura a
Dr Laura comments. Here we go. Uh,
wait a minute. Wait a minute. I've
got to get a secretary for this shit.
All right. Where the fuck are
we? Yeah, I fucking hate youtube.
I don't want you douchebags doing the
fucking thing. I want the actual guy.
Everybody doing a fucking remix.
Wait, hang on. Hang in there.
Yeah,
there it is. There we go. Alright,
now this one's mainly going to be
for, uh, the people that I offended
last week, last week,
uh, with a fuck is it?
Come on now. All right, here we go.
Here we go. This isn't going to remind,
this isn't going to remind you of a movie.
This is going to remind you of a TV
show. What show was this? Hang on.
What's the last one?
Come on. Wait a minute.
You fucking cunt. I
didn't hit pause. Did I?
Hang on.
All right,
this is going to remind you of a TV show.
What TV show.
I somehow missed that one that came out.
That is a, that's the Carlton Dance.
I think I was too old for that one. I
kind of tapped out with sitcoms after, uh,
after why happy days
and I wanted the chairs.
I started boozing and actually
believed cheers. You know,
I believe that,
you know,
there was a bar like that and you come
in and just being an alcoholic was like
funny and fulfilling.
I guess there was the sadness.
He completely avoided his wife,
Vera. And they never showed her. Um,
anyways. You know what? I think that's
going to be the podcast for the week.
I have to, I got a tap out
here, man. This, this, uh,
this is trying to do one on the road.
The day after I come off the road
is really difficult. But, uh,
fortunately things have been
going well that I'm really busy,
so I guess that is a good fucking thing.
But you know,
you get used to this comedian lifestyle.
Well you just get the fucking hang
out on a Monday. Now I actually, uh,
I have shit to do,
which is annoying.
It's not why I started being a comedian.
I started to be a comedian,
so I would not have shit to do,
you know,
wouldn't have a boss
to tell fucking jokes,
talk about my Dick and all 50 states
and whatnot. Believe it or not,
people, my neck stand up date
isn't until September 9th, uh,
at the comedy works in Denver, Colorado.
Let's blow through some dates, shall we,
by the way, uh, my tickets
from my big theater show,
my big theater tour that I'm doing,
um,
are on sale now. And, uh, I don't have
the fucking link. Do I? Where is it?
Oh,
you go to live nation.com.
MMM.
[inaudible]
slash bill birth tickets or you just go
to [inaudible] dot com you just click on
any, any of the dates here? I'm going to
be a, before the theater's tour starts.
I mean also going to be as
Zany comedy club in Nashville,
Tennessee on September 23rd,
24th and 25th,
one of, uh, one of my favorite clubs to
play as is the comedy works in Denver.
September 10th. Well, we
got there September 10th,
11th. I have September 9th,
10th and the 11th. There we go.
That's when I'm working there. Um,
and then starts the theater shit.
I'm going to be at the egg in Albany,
New York.
All you people in upstate New York always
say, come to upstate New York, man.
What the fuck?
I'm going to be there.
I'm going to be at the egg in Albany,
New York.
And then the following day I'm going
to be at the center for the arts,
Buffalo, New York. Um,
so I'm finally coming to buffalo.
I'm actually hitting up a bunch of
towns that I haven't been to in fucking
forever. Uh, another city, a city.
I've never done standup in a full set.
I've done a guest set,
but I've never gotten a gig out there.
I'm going to be at the, uh, pantageous
Pantages pan on ages, whatever the
fuck it is, theater in Minneapolis,
Minnesota on October 22nd.
And then the following
day I'm going to be at
the Vic Theater in Chicago,
Illinois on, um, October 23rd.
And uh, any other ones? I
got another theater date.
On November 19th.
I met the listener auditorium,
Washington DC and a,
the last theater I have is
the more theater in Seattle,
Washington on November 27th.
Uh,
you can go on to build bird.com and just
click on the links in the lower left
hand corner and you can
check out all that bullshit.
And, uh, hopefully you'll come out to
the shows. We'll see how it goes. Um,
for those of you wondering if I'm just
going to try to do theaters exclusively,
um, no, I am not. I'm always
going to be doing the, the clubs.
I like the gym keeps you in shape.
You come in, you do five, six shows,
and then every once in awhile like,
uh, like Buffalo, I don't know.
They don't really have like a
big time comedy club out there.
No disrespect to anybody out there.
So why you just come in,
you try to do a theater. Same
thing with Albany, you know,
you start going to those really
smaller fucking towns, um,
or smaller comedy markets. And
then that's just when, you know,
the local comedy club is just the
name, you know, like knee slappers,
you know, um, God dammit, you're funny.
Who's ready to laugh, you know, they
just got awful fucking names and uh,
yeah. And they try to make
you stay in a comedy condo.
So that's why I always
avoided those things.
And I tried to stay in the
bigger markets where I could,
they actually put me in a hotel. I'm
like, you, I lie like my comforts. So,
uh, that's, that's the big,
uh, my big tour coming up.
And there's also a date there I missed in
Columbus, Ohio. That's a club date, uh,
November 12th, 13th, and 14th.
And the fucking, you know,
what kills me is how quick that's all
gonna go by and another year is going to
go by as well as, you know,
by the end of that tour, um,
football season will be three quarters
over. How fucking sad is that?
At least the regular season.
Uh, who do you like by the way?
Anybody?
Anybody for some predictions.
How about we try to do some predictions
and whoever comes to fucking closest
gets a, an autograph and
autographed DVD in my brand new DVD,
let it go. Because by then it'll be the
end of the season, I'll fucking said, Nah,
I'm not going to do that. Then
you won't fucking buy it. Right.
I need to get you to buy it. Got,
damn it. I suck at marketing. Anyways,
that's a podcast for this week. It
was very disjointed. I, you know,
they can't all be gold.
You know,
even Peyton manning throws an interception
every once in awhile and the file
drive of a fucking Superbowl
doesn't he? Well, doesn't,
he actually saw what's his face? Uh,
drew Brees finally getting some props.
He came in there with John Gruden,
you know,
John Grooms got that
unbelievable intensity that,
that vein down the middle of his forehead.
That's one of my favorite
announcers out there, or color men,
whatever the hell that guy's
doing that guys to shift.
There's nothing better than an
ex football player. And this is,
this is provided that they
have broadcasting skills.
Someone either played the game,
coached the game and that type of shit.
And then you get the classic
like broadcast or like a,
like an Al Michaels or something like
that to call the game. And then, uh,
then you got your crew.
Thank you bill.
Thank you for breaking that down
as if we didn't fucking notice.
Why don't you just admit,
Bill,
that you're just babbling at this point
to somehow try and make it to, Oh,
I'm up to 57 minutes. That qualifies.
I can tap out at this point.
Don't you guys leave sometimes
three minutes before five.
So what did we learn this week?
We learned that even on major topics
like race bill really doesn't do his
research.
Uh,
we learned that I had at why that I got
some fat guy with the milky white ties
to laugh at himself and he's lost 40
pounds. So I'm not totally a bad guy.
And uh, I guess from the troops come
back, send them a drink or get, get, um,
get him a blow job or shut your
face. And evidently they, they,
they feel the same way of the support.
The troop bumper stickers as I do.
You like how I'm taking one marine,
his point of view and just saying
that that's everybody's well,
that's what the fuck I do. That's
what I do. Support the troops.
I always thought it was ridiculous.
What are those bumper stickers that said,
I support the troops? It's like,
well, why wouldn't you? What do you,
what are you rooting for the,
the other team.
So fucking obvious. I support the
troops. Ice Cream tastes good.
I like babies.
You know what?
He's gonna have all kinds
of obvious bumper stickers
on the back of your fucking
car. I saw a guy at a
big heart on, on his,
on his side of his house.
It said love our troops.
It just really gave me the creeps and
every time I see it I want to fucking rip
it down. Yeah, no, I,
this other guy wrote me an angry fucking
email all about the politics about
sending the troops over there,
you know? And it's just like,
like he was fucking dropping
all this knowledge, man,
about what's really going on
with the war man. You know,
like, I don't realize, like
I don't realize that shit,
but I also realized that those guys
don't determine where the fuck they go.
All right. So I'll just try not to be a
Dick, you know, pick up in a dick enough,
haven't I?
I've gotta be honest with you.
I have no idea what I said
for the last 11 minutes,
but all I know is I recorded it and you're
listening to it. Okay. So who's worse?
Me. You guys just shaking your heads right
now. Who's really losing his mind? Well,
maybe I am. Um, that's it.
So I got it. I got like two,
three weeks off on be hanging out.
Can we go?
I'm doing a lot of spots down the
comedy store. If you're in Los Angeles,
gotta be working out my shit. If you want
to come down there and watch me bomb,
lean on the mic, stand and stare
at that. All weather carpet is,
I work out my bits, uh, pop in down
the comedy store and that's it. Thanks.
Everybody wrote in and uh,
and that is that.
I'll talk to you guys next week.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].